hello my name is ajay kamar i'm a senior
principal research manager at microsoft
research at redmond
today i will be speaking with my
colleague besmiro nushi
who is also a senior researcher at
microsoft research
and we are a member of a team called
adaptive systems and interaction
today it is our pleasure to talk about
the work we are doing on responsible ai
in particular bringing responsible ai to
reality to the practices
of microsoft with bismillah and i
and many other colleagues at microsoft
we have been part of a journey
journey of implementing responsible ai
at a company of the size of
microsoft and making sure that we are
developing the right best practices
tools engineering principles needed
to bring responsible ai into reality and
today i will be talking about this
journey with you
talk about the lessons we have learned
on the way and how our learnings are
influencing the research we are doing at
microsoft research
let's start with a quick outline i will
start with a quick introduction on
responsible ai
then i will talk about what lessons we
have learned
through the journey of trying to
implement our work at microsoft
and i will also talk about how this is
influencing the research we are
we are doing bismillah will continue
with three distinct
tools that provide lenses into model
performance
this tooling work is very important for
ensuring that the systems we are
building building in the company are
reliable
these tools are on air analysis model
comparison
and backward compatibility we will
conclude the discussion on future
directions
so just to start the discussion in the
last decade we have witnessed big
advances in
artificial intelligence and we see
examples from these
when we are looking into vision tasks
language tasks
or games where ai systems are now
mastering
this is all very exciting as an ai
researcher to myself
and it has been exciting for our larger
community
and for the world overall reaching human
level parity on these tasks
and mastering games like go or pac-man
have created big expectations about the
opportunity of putting ai systems into
the real world
in 2016 some experts predicted that
most radiology tasks would be automated
by now
or we would have fully self-driving cars
on the streets
now looking back in 2021 it is
safe to say that the speed of moving ai
into the real world
has not been as fast or as easy
as some experts have predicted so why
this
is the case why the speed of
acceleration into the real world
has been slower or rougher than expected
when we look examples of ai systems
being applied to domains that matter for
our society
like decision making in courts decision
making in healthcare
or physical ai systems that interact
with people or could
cause for um for humans we
see that how these systems function and
more importantly
how these systems make mistakes in the
real world
have consequences for people who are
using them
people who are interacting with them and
for our society
an important requirement for an ai
system acting in the real world
is reliability when an ai system is
deployed in the real world
we expect that system to work as
specified
as expected by its designers under many
different conditions
when the lighting conditions are
changing when the use cases are changing
when there are unexpected conditions in
which the system is being used or when
there are corner cases or
outliers and even most importantly
when we have different users user groups
and sometimes these users may include
underrepresented groups
these are all getting into the
expectation of what we
expect from a reliable machine learning
or ai system
and reliability is a central principle
that applies to
every ai systems that are being
developed to be deployed
into the real world however in the in
the real world
lack of reliability may manifest itself
in different ways
when we are talking about reliability
for a self-driving car
lack of reliability may manifest itself
as a safety issue
for example when a self-driving car like
in this example
may misrecognize some flags or pictures
on the flags
as stop signs i may may start acting
as if it is actually a stop sign
on an issue like face recognition
issues with reliability the fact that
these systems are not working equally
well
across different groups may manifest
itself as a fairness problem
and in fact as a is a problem around
disproportional error rates
and even in cases where having lack of
reliability
may not lead to a safety problem or a
fairness problem
these systems not working reliably
across different use cases may create
problems with user trust
users losing trust with these systems
and stop using them
so recognizing that these reliability
is a central concern to the development
and deployment of ai systems in the real
world
as early as 2016 microsoft released its
responsible ai principles
and surprisingly one of the these
principles
is about reliability so what are these
it's fairness ensuring that the systems
we are developing are fair
they are reliable they are respecting
people's privacy and they are secure
they are inclusive for different people
we have in our society
they are transparent when needed and
they are accountable
for their mistakes
of course releasing these principles
into the world
is an important but easy part
bringing them to reality and making sure
that all ai systems developed in a
company that is the size of microsoft
is the real challenge that we are
involved with to achieve this goal
microsoft
at microsoft we form the ether committee
which stands for ai ethics and effects
in engineering
and research and researchers have been a
central part of this initiative from the
very beginning
for the last few years i've been
co-leading the work on reliability and
safety
and also acting as a technical advisor
for this effort
working together with many researchers
from msr
including best mirandushi and also
collaborating with different parts of
the company
since the inception of this ether
committee we
have worked across the company to
educate teams on the responsible ai
challenges
to provide consultancy and support on
specific cases
and develop guidance tools and best
practices
to enable practitioners in bringing
these responsible ai principles into
practice
and while we are doing this work we are
also very happy to see that
our responsible ai ecosystem
is growing at the company because the
success on a mission like this
requires a company-wide effort and a
mature organization
spanning research legal teams and
product groups
today ethers research and development
efforts in the company are supported by
two sister organizations
one in our legal department thinking a
lot about developing a standard across
the company and doing sensitive use
reviews
about how to develop our ai systems
we also have race and engineering arm
that support
engineering groups to implement our
responsible ai
principles and standards and bringing
them into reality and we are working
closely with this ecosystem
so why did i tell you about what we are
doing at microsoft and our ecosystem
it's because i want to tell you about
some of the lessons we have learned
through this journey by working closely
with our legal
colleagues and also with our engineering
colleagues
so the first lesson we have learned
through the way
responsible ai emerges from
understanding ai
limitations in the open world when you
look into
how ai systems are developed today and
how people are talking about the success
of ai
it mainly talks about lab conditions
where ai systems
are tested on static test sets or
on simulation platforms or games where
things are pretty constrained
here you are seeing a video of air sim a
car trying to learn in this environment
and it is a pretty controlled
environment as you can see
however what we are seeing case over
case
is that results we are getting in the
lab when it is nicely controlled and
measured on static test sets do not
necessarily generalize to the open world
where we have outlier cases that are not
necessarily included
into the lab conditions here you are
seeing a picture
of a car driving in a different
environment much different than what
airsim the simulation platform was
showing
and you can see here that this looks
pretty different than the simulation
environment i just shown you
therefore it is so important to have
efforts
in in these ai training and development
to leave the lab and get into the real
world
and have tools and work that focuses on
how to ensure real world ai reliability
when these systems are deployed for real
so that is something we are going to be
talking about today
inside number two there is no silver
single silver's bullet
to the responsible ai challenge that
challenges that we are seeing
across the different cases that um that
we we see
why that is the case first of all
developing
ai an ai system is much more than just
training a model with some data
when we look into the ai life cycle we
see that
this life cycle has many stages from
defining model requirements
data collection data cleaning thinking
about the design
then model development but then thinking
about model evaluation deployment
deployment
and monitoring having these different
stages mean that
problems can occur at different stages
of the ai life cycle
so we have to support developers
designers
and the developer and the community at
each step
of this ai lifecycle second of all
we have to acknowledge that ai systems
do not emerge
separately from the human effort we have
to acknowledge that ai is developed by
people
with people and for people what i mean
by that is
people are involved at every stage of
this ai life cycle
therefore it is important to educate
them and also
provide support to them at different
stages
but another point that is coming from
this sentence
is that when we look into the
application domains like
hiring or medical spaces or
legal decision making the problems we
see
are not only technology problems they
are in fact socio-technical problems
the issues here are deeply rooted in the
society we live in
so when we are thinking about developing
responsible ai solutions
we cannot treat these problems as only
technology problems
we need to be working with domain
experts and need to reason about all
of the stakeholders involved this just
makes our
challenges a bit more complex
and the third insight if we want to
achieve our goals on responsible ai
we have to align our efforts with ai
development
and our ai developers
we have done a study which was
which won the best paper awards in 2019
at this conference in this study
we talked to more than 500 different
machine learning
engineers and developers at microsoft at
our company
and we learned a lot of things you can't
read the details at this paper
but they complain about the lack of
tooling support
um not having tool integration
being able just having have to going
from one experience to the next and to
the next and to the next and this
creating fragmentation
but they also flag some areas where we
just have to put more effort into
supporting them
and these include debugging how do you
know where your models are
performing badly model evaluation and
deployment
so when in the ai world when we are
thinking about ai tooling
most people think about tools that
support model training however we need
to expand our vision and think about all
of the parts of the ai life cycle
where developers need support
and most importantly some people may
think that responsible is
ai is just something nice to have
something we need to worry about when we
are deploying our systems we disagree
with this
for us responsible ai is analogous
to good engineering and we have to
work towards developing the right
engineering principles
and tooling and practices to be able to
just
have the same engineering rigor when we
are developing
ai as we are developing any other
traditional software
and our challenge is that we need to
figure out what these tools are going to
look like when we are talking about ai
systems
and in our investigations we realize
that the path to deploying reliable
machine learning
systems is still unpaved so there's so
much work we need to be doing
and that's great news to us as
researchers because this gives us so
much work to do
so much so many new problems to get
excited about
so the vision we have for our work and
the work
that we are going to be presenting today
is that
we work on building tools and
methodologies
that help engineers accelerate the
development iterations
of the ai life cycle so what we are
saying is that
when we are thinking about ai
reliability we
have to be thinking about a continuous
loop we have to identify where our
systems are failing
or not working as well as expected
diagnose where
these problems are coming from and
mitigate that
and do this continuously as we are
learning from the real world from the
real world deployment of these systems
and by doing so and by supporting teams
in the cycle then we can get faster
um at the work that we are doing and we
can be rigorous and systematic in our
principles
so the three tools mirror will be
demoing today and talking about today
are really about putting lenses into
performance evaluation of ai systems
the first tooling on air analysis is
going to be talking about the
initial development we have one model
one benchmark data
and how we are evaluating it now we look
into the current practices of evaluation
it is actually it is
infancy when we read ai papers or people
talk about ai performance
they usually talk about one or a few
aggregate numbers
like my system is 73.8 percent accurate
however that single number is hiding so
much complexity
about model performance when we look and
examine models
in and their performance in more detail
we see that this
performance metric is not uniform across
the subspaces that this model is
evaluated on
in fact there are pockets of data where
models are doing really really good
and there are pockets of data where
these models are not working equally
well
and it is so important to have these
glances to these pockets of data where
the performance is significantly
differing
because by doing so we will know where
our models are reliable and
where our models are not reliable and
also we can take the necessary actions
to improve them and get into that
continuous improvement loop
but we also see that model performance
evaluation is not limited to
one model when we are continuously
updating our models
because we may have more data or we are
switching to a new architecture
we usually check if our new model has a
higher accuracy or higher aggregate
metric than
our baseline model what we've seen in
our work and besmira will be talking a
lot more about this
is that just seeing these aggregate
numbers going up
does not mean that our next model is
going to be better in fact when we look
at the venn diagram like this
what we see is that the new model maybe
is improving on some things but could
also be regressing on some things
and a great motivating scenario for for
why we are doing this is the gender
shades
shade story um the research work done by
joe balomani and timnit gabriel
where they have shown that for public
models for predicting the gender from
images the models that are deployed in
the real world could have very different
performance across different groups of
people
on the dimensions of gender or race
so why we are seeing this proportional
error rates for different subspaces of
data
in the work that we have done um in 2017
we have shown that these disproportional
error rates happen
because the data lack of representation
and data
can break the fundamental assumption of
machine learning
which is the training data has
coverage for all of the cases that the
model is going to be
seeing in the future however when that
assumption is broken
for example in this case we are building
a classifier
about cats and dogs and let's imagine
that some groups of
dogs were not represented in training
data for example small white dogs
what we end up seeing is that the model
learning from this data
has much higher error rates um
when they see for example white dots the
subspaces that are not well represented
in the training data and when this
happens when our training data has
blind spots the models learning from
data
make mistakes in the open world that are
called unknown unknowns
where they are making mistakes with high
confidence because they are not really
expecting these
mistakes to happen they are just their
blind spots
in our 2017 paper we have developed a
framework a two-stage framework
for debugging and testing these models
these two stages included descriptive
space partitioning
and a search algorithm with martial arm
bandits however this
technique was quite complicated
so what beza is going to be showing you
is follow-up work
that actually makes a lot of these
approaches
really developer friendly
why we are thinking about debugging
because
once we understand the errors in these
models
then we can go and improve them and this
is exactly what happened with our
face apis once the research work
identified these disproportional error
rates
so after reading the paper from timnit
and joy
the developer team went and collected
more data to diversify
the training data set and as a result of
that now
um back then the models had improved um
very significantly
um for for this task
so on this motivation what i want to
leave out at
levat is um we need these lenses to be
able to understand
where our errors are so that developers
can take the necessary steps at
improving that
improving them and this is the key to
ensuring
ai reliability so now besmiry is going
to be diving into the tree tooling
that is making these principles
developer friendly and bringing them to
the real to the real world so i'll hand
it off to beth
next hi everyone and um thanks for being
with us
in this webinar my name is bismi anushi
and i'm going to guide you through
the tools that we have built for
implementing principles for our
responsible ai
aja made an excellent case for why
is indeed a must-have aspect for
excellent and rigorous machine learning
engineering
in order to support these principles and
insights that we have shared so far
in the past years we have worked closely
with several teams at microsoft to build
tools
that can help practitioners implement
these principles especially on
reliability and safety
now um we have a vision for supporting
the whole machine learning uh life cycle
from error identification to diagnosis
and mitigation
the figure here maps the tools that we
have built so far
on this picture of the machine learning
improvement life cycle
a lot of this has been internal tooling
and infrastructure and most recently we
have worked on building these tools as
open source
offerings and jupyter widgets first
you can think of um error analysis as a
tool for supporting
identification and diagnosis of errors
and then
the two other pieces on model comparison
and backward compatibility
as support for um closing up this loop
and comparing models with each other but
also for mitigating regress
issues by being able to train compatible
models
so let's get started with error analysis
in fact the uh the work on error
analysis started
early in 2018 when we proposed a
methodology
for doing in-depth failure um
understanding for machine learning
just like in the um greek tale pandora
opens up the box of system inputs
and it chops it in several semantic
clusters
and then for each semantic cluster that
is defined either via content features
or the internal state of several machine
learning components
then um we build interpretable models
that can
explain when the model performs well and
when it doesn't so since then we have
advanced these ideas quite a bit
we implemented them as a tool
and now this is going to be open source
you can see the
github repository here and we're happy
to take
our feedback and also looking forward to
your uh
contributions this uh tool consists of
uh several visualizations that are
intended
either for doing identification or
diagnosis
so uh let me show you how we use this
tool uh for better understanding the
benchmark on the gender shade study
about which edu just talked about now
something to notice here is that while
the task may not be the most
representative one
for phase vision it is a very good task
for showing how certain societal biases
can creep into models
and how nuanced and complicated a story
can be
when it comes to testing for reliability
all the results that we are going to
look um together
are results that are based on an old
gender detection model
which was significantly improved after
the gender shades paper
uh came out and we use the same data set
the parliament data set that consists of
photos of
candidates of parliaments across
northern europe and africa
and then we also further augmented the
benchmark with
attributes that we either collected via
human annotation for example
hair length or whether um the lighting
in the photo is good or not
and then also from attributes from the
face um
azure api that tells us whether a person
is wearing glasses
or whether they're wearing makeup and
other face attributes
so let's see here we see a screenshot
from the tool
on the left hand side you can see the
meta attributes that were used to do
error analysis and then on the right
hand side you can
see a tree that was trained to best
separate the errors from
successes so um we are going to look at
two different visual indicators
uh the first one is color the darker the
node in the tree uh in in red
the higher the error rate is going to be
for that node
and then the other indicator is the
field line the field line
tells us how many of the errors that
occur in the whole benchmark
are actually concentrated in that
particular node
so ideally we would want to see these
nodes that are not only um in dark red
but they also have a high fill line
in this particular case for this
benchmark we see that
the bayes error rate is 5.5
and then we if we continue to follow
this red critical path
then we can see that for women the error
rate increases to 11.5 percent
and then it increases even more if um
you are a woman and you are not wearing
uh eye makeup in the photo it increases
even more if you also
uh do not have long or medium length
hair
and then it the error finally becomes
35.7
if you're also not smiling in the forum
so we're talking here
about an increase of uh seven times in
error
for this particular group and this as
you can see this is a
super complex uh pattern of error that
is very difficult for the engineer to uh
account for ahead of time without the
help of
automated tools now um
let's go back and uh think about suppose
we found this problem
what happens next and uh also how is
this pattern related to the fact that
the model makes more mistakes
for women with a darker skin tone well
now that we know these important factors
for failure then we can go and look back
at the distributions of data
for these particular factors and this is
exactly what we are showing in this
graph
we say that there exists dramatic
distributional differences between
women with a darker skin tone and those
with a lighter skin tone we see
that women with a darker skin tone are
less likely in this particular data set
to uh have longer hair or wait or wear
makeup
and both factors contribute to an error
increase
and this can give us really you know a
deeper insight about the story here
it means that we can do further uh
targeted mitigation
instead of just collecting data
everywhere for this benchmark
we could target our data collection into
this particular pocket for example
for women with a darker skin tone that
have shorter hair
or for women that are not wearing any
eye makeup
in order to have uh you know a more
planned and informed
mitigation plan um
so as i mentioned the tool is now in the
open source
you can find it in this link and um
something else that we
did in order to boost the
functionalities of this
tool is to enable further diagnosis
one part of diagnosis is data diagnosis
which
we showed with the distributional graphs
earlier on
but yet another thing that you can do is
to look at the most
important factors for the model that led
to that prediction
and so we are using um primitives from
the interpreter ml library this is also
an open source tool
for interpretability that helps us to
identify the main factors
not only globally or locally for
particular instances
for all but also for particular or you
know cohorts of data that
are more problematic
um in fact let's for a better
understanding we are going to take a
look at a demo together
before the demo i also want to um uh
thank our collaborators in azure machine
learning that made the
open sourcing of this tool possible
let's take a look at
the demo so um the demo actually runs in
the jupyter notebooks environment you
can import the error analysis dashboard
from the responsible ai
widget and you can call the dashboard by
uh giving it as an input you know
parameters like
the ground truth or the explanations for
the data
or for example transformational
pipelines that you might have used if
the data or some features
are categorical you can look at the
widget here
but you can also um open it up in a
different app in order to have a better
visualization so um let's see
we first are going to go through the
error identification
visualizations this is one of them and
it's similar to the three that i showed
earlier for gender shades
and we can see that the base error rate
for this task is 12.5 percent
in fact uh the task that we are going to
look at is based on
a model that was trained on the uci
census data set
and um this data set has information on
for example whether um
the age of a person gender education and
marital status
and the final task is to predict whether
this individual is earning
more than 50k or less than 50k a year
and um this is a pretty common data set
that is used
uh in these settings and um now we are
going to solo some of the critical paths
that seem to be more
problematic for example we see that for
this particular uh
pocket of the data for example for
people who are
married they have a lower number of
education years
and they are older than 33 the error
rate
becomes 25 percent meaning that it is
doubling
um in in rate and we can also see
that for this other uh cluster here
for people who are again married they
have a high number of education years
and they are younger than 33
the error rate also increases to 28
percent
and perhaps this might be people who um
who are married but they might be still
studying
and they haven't had a chance to uh to
work yet
and um again this is an information that
we do not have in the data set
but it's something that we uh that we
can find out with
uh with this tools yet another
uh error identification um primitive
that we can look at
is the heat map so in the heat map we
can see
the dependency between certain features
and
error rate for example if i want to look
at the number of education years
then i can see that for uh people who
have a higher
number of education years the error rate
becomes higher
i can again slice this um with another
dimension for example
by gender and we can see that these
discrepancies in performance are higher
for
men in this particular case so we can
see that these differences are more
visible for
for men but then we can again do more
and
deep dive into particular clusters of
data for example
we can create a cohort that we may want
to investigate
further directly from the interface
for example we can say that i want to
look at this cohort later
and then this is another cohort that is
only for individuals who are not married
and then i can continue to look at this
data in the
explanation side of things first i can
do active data exploration
for instance i may want to see how is
the ground rule distributed
basically i am selecting the true y
here and also the distribution in the y
axis and i can see that for the whole
data
the data looks a little bit skewed
meaning that there are more
individuals in this data set that are
earning less than 50k
in comparison to those that are earning
more
and then we can see how this looks in
particular for the cohorts that we just
uh
created for example we see that for the
not married
um individuals the story is again skewed
but perhaps a little bit more
and for individuals who are married this
looks uh
more balanced meaning that um this can
explain
why the task of predicting income for
individuals who are married becomes more
difficult for the model
because this data looks a lot more
different than
the overall data distribution uh yet
another
um another functionality that i might
have from the diagnosis side
is to generate global explanations and
to understand these factors
and this is basically what these graphs
are showing us and
uh for instance we see that both for the
married and non-merit cohort
marital status is important for the
model because these values are high
but it seems that for the not married uh
cohort
age is um more important and for the
married cohort capital gain is more
important
meaning that um the model is sort of
treating this
um these cohorts differently and taking
different
decisions and then i can uh
go ahead and i can look at local
explanations for each
particular data point i can look at
correct predictions
incorrect predictions and i can for
example pick to
uh you know investigate one data point
further
if i were interested in for example i
can pick this particular data point i
can generate
uh what if um you know explanations for
this particular
data point i can look at if this person
for instance had
15 years old of education how would it
change
the um you know the prediction in this
case is it going to
um is it going to make a change in the
model when in fact we can
we can see that uh the prediction
changes it becomes
uh accurate if we change the number of
uh education years
so um again this is um this is
the summary of what the tool can provide
for you on
the day however um in the future we
are also thinking about further
integrations
uh we also have other offerings from
for example our lab in msr new york
on fairness assessments and mitigations
and in the context of responsible ai we
believe that
the real value of these tools can come
if we
provide the frameworks where all of them
interoperate together
and when the engineer can come in and
use them without having to jump
from one side or to the other
so um we have deployed the tool
internally in several scenarios
when we look back at testimonials from
our teams
then two main themes come up the first
theme is air identification
in um in this way our team say
it is much easier to identify errors and
then it becomes difficult to overlook
them
afterwards if you have them in front of
you with a tool
and then the other important thing is
targeted mitigation
by knowing the heat map of how errors
are
distributed it becomes more easier to do
targeted mitigation because then you can
collect more data for that particular
pocket
instead of doing unguided and expensive
data collection
now we are currently also continuing to
do more research in order to
um you know increase the um the
impact of these tools for uh supporting
rich media
such as images and language i will give
you a few examples on each of these
for example on the image side the
functionality of feature extraction
or attribute generation is something
that came up from
our discussions with internal customers
we noticed that different teams may be
at different levels of maturity
for example some of them may have a lot
of metadata available but some of them
may not
and if you do not have this metadata
available then
by just looking at the images on failure
cases
and success cases left and right it
becomes difficult to understand what the
pattern is
for example in this case you are looking
at failure instances
and success instances for a
model that was trained on imagenet on
the particular
uh class of image classification for uh
for detecting seat belts and the base
error rate here
is 33 and again we can look at these
images but
it's hard to find any pattern and so
what we did is that
we did more research on feature
augmentation
and extraction many of you may already
know that the features that are
extracted by deep learning models
many times may not be interpretable or
visible
to the human eye so what we did is that
we employed robust models because there
has been
um recent research evidence that
the features extracted by such models
are more interpretable and this is
research that was done
at um mit but by its pure acetal
and what we did is that we checked how
these features may be
useful for doing error analysis and we
did feature extraction and then build
custom
feature visualizations to explain to the
developer what these features may mean
for instance in this case you can see
that for this particular two images
we have extracted these features that
seem to be focusing in this case
on grass even when we emphasize them the
photo
starts to contain more grass and then we
make this available to the error
analysis process and try to
find patterns so going back to the
previous example on
a seat belt among all the features
that we extracted there was this one
that was pretty
predictive of failure and in particular
if this feature was not present
we see the error rate to increase for
the class of seat belt and when we
visualize the feature we can see that
the feature represents human hair
and in other words what this means is
that this model had a difficult time to
detect seat belts
when there is no human hair present in
the photo
which in fact reveals a serious point of
brittleness about the model
if we were to deploy the model in the
real world
now again we can go back and look at
these failure examples
and now we see that in fact there is
either no
hair in this photos or very little and
again these are these those types of
failures that are difficult to
uh to find out if you just look at the
images one by one
and this is where these tools uh may
help us um
we have applied this uh method in for
both robust and non-robust uh
models and in the case of non-robust
models
or standard models you can think about
this feature extraction
as a content descriptor basically
something that can
describe for you the input and then
correlate those descriptions with
the failure of the model now on the
language
side um i wanted to mention a project
that is led by marco ribeiro also in our
group
the tool is called checklist and uh what
it does for you for language data
is that it offers certain templates that
can help you
to understand um the failures of uh
language models but also to guide your
certain decisions that might be
made in a large company about model
release
when it comes to large language models
and and i'd suggest you to take a look
as well
um so uh let's continue with uh the next
set of tools on model comparison and
backward compatibility
now as eljan mentioned earlier um
accuracy or aggregate accuracy alone
cannot be the only indicator for us to
take a decision
on which model to deploy next well we
hope that our models
will remain fully compatible and they
will not introduce any new mistakes when
we
make an update in practice
incompatibility and new errors can
happen for
many different reasons they can happen
because of optimization stochasticity
because the data may be different it may
have noise or distributional shifts
or just because you know the new
architecture may be fundamentally
different from the old one
and so um all these you know concerns
raise the need for
considering these models not just as
isolated component
but to put them into an overall system
perspective
when we think about these models not
just as isolated components but
models that will work with other
software components or models that are
going to work perhaps
with a human and um therefore we suggest
to look at compatibility scores as well
um except accuracy for example in this
case the trust uh compatibility score
is um is a score that tells us
uh how much trust was preserved during
the update
meaning how many of the examples that
were initially right are still
correct and then the error compatibility
score
tells us which portions of errors are
are not new now we did experiments and
this is a
work that is led by uh gadam bansal at
the university of uh
washington and uh we saw that for cases
for example
like mortality prediction that was
trained in um in a medical
domain we see that compatibility can be
as low as 40 percent
meaning that 60 of the cases that were
initially correct
are now going to be wrong and so what we
proposed
uh back then is to use a reformulated
loss function
that tells us or that takes into account
not only
log loss as a measure of accuracy but
also the dissonance between the first
version of the model
and the second version and in this case
um in the newer dissonance which is also
the one that worked best for
our experiment basically we are adding
an additional loss every time the old
model was correct
and by using this type of regularization
then you can
generate these um exploration graphs
between compatibility
and accuracy in the y-axis and uh every
dot that you see in this graph is a
different model
and so this becomes a tool for the
developer to
make an informed decision on which model
to uh to deploy for example they can say
that
perhaps i don't want to sacrifice any
new accuracy and so i may want to pick
models that are
in um in this flat area here and perhaps
if compatibility is an important uh you
know aspect for my deployment
then maybe i want to to go in this area
so um we also think that uh backward
compatibility can be a way for us to
identify potential
issues with the data in this particular
experiment uh that uh that is part of
our
quality paper that it was uh led by
megazil rastava
here we see that um even though we
applied the data update the data
was much larger we introduced this
synthetic noise in label between car
and track and after the update we see
that in overall
the impact is positive which is the gray
line here
but the um the classes on car and track
were most effective
and from incompatibility because of the
noise and again this becomes a tool
that other developer can use to uh
select the data in these histograms and
look at what
the label noise problem is there
so um to package these ideas together
into a usable tool we started a
collaboration with the ether engineering
team
um and they have packaged this as a
library and library and widget
and this is the github repository for
this widget
it contains the loss functions that i
talked about but also
a um widget visualization tool that we
are going to see next
um so this is how
the tool uh looks like for backward
compatibility
you can uh here i have two classifiers
h1 and h2
and um i'm doing backward you know
compatibility analysis
the data set in this case is um a data
set that was trained in order to predict
the credit score
of a certain individual and this is
something that you might find you know
applied in
certain financial domains and uh we can
we have a choice
to select you know whether we want to do
this analysis on training data or on
test data we can pick the dissonance
factor in this case and i can see that
we have choice
on many different models for example i
can pick
this model that seems to have like a
good trade-off uh for instance this is
the model that was trained with
lambda 0 but if i look a little bit
further like i can find even a better
model
and then i can also focus on each of
these and see how much regress
and how much progress was introduced if
i were to visualize this in the form of
a venn diagram
basically i am merging you know um the
two
types of errors together here old model
and new model
and see how much intersection there is
in the types of errors
and how many of the errors are actually
disjoint
i can also see the distribution of
incompatible points for example
if i were to pick this model here we see
that incompatibility is sort of
biased towards this particular class so
perhaps this is a model that i will not
want to deploy but maybe i am going to
look at something more
balanced like this one um it is also
possible to use this in vision data for
example this is an experiment that we
run
on the amnes data set um this is
again two models and now as you can
notice
here i'm using the widget just for model
comparison
if i were just if i was interested just
to compare these two models with each
other
and i can look at the distribution in
different classes i can see that class 9
in terms of digits here is more affected
i can click at this class and i can look
at the particular instances that
um are incompatible one after the other
so i hope this gives you you know a
flavor of uh what these
um widgets look like of course there is
so much more that can be done
with respect to model comparison and
also
our analysis and we're looking forward
to your contributions as well
um so um to summarize our efforts
um i also want to discuss you know
future
opportunities and challenges along the
way we all have a vision
on building end-to-end tool uh
interoperability
uh there exist our other challenges that
we would like to
tackle in the future related to
connecting the data analytics story with
model analytics because this is super
important
um you know data management perhaps has
been a little bit detached for
from model analytics in the past but now
they are so close to each other and we
believe that these two stories
need to be uh linked even more
the use of these tools needs to be
interactive and scalable
as you saw no analysis finishes with one
click
and um some of these experiences they
are useful
exactly because they are interactive and
allow you to dig more
to conclude um i want to say that if we
want ai to keep its promise on
economical growth
and increase productivity we need to
prioritize responsible ai
and the rigor that it brings to making
our systems better
um here are a few resources for you to
take a look at
um i also want to introduce you to our
group
um in fact there are a lot more people
in our group that work on
centered artificial intelligence and
responsible ai
if you are a student that is looking for
an internship or
um or researcher positions then feel
free to drop us an email to
and um and we'll take it from there so
thank you and we hope to see you in the
q a
feel free to come in and we'll discuss
there
thanks
hi everyone um thanks so much for being
with us here
and attending our webinar on bringing
responsible ai principles into
practice with concrete tools and open
source libraries
my name is bes miranushi and i'm here
together with ajay kamar
together with aj in the next 15 minutes
we're going to be answering
top questions that you all have sent in
our um
chat and um so with no further ado let's
get started
um the first question that i'd like to
pick here that's
inapp actually submitted in our chat is
a is asking
uh does responsible ai um sometimes
go against company growth
xena this is a great question uh we
discuss
about this uh very often in microsoft
but also in
larger forums so the take that we are
taking on this as aj also responded in
the
chat is that responsible ai should be
considered as a
discipline that advocates for excellence
in
engineering many of the aspects that we
talked about today such as testing
debugging or doing proper evaluation on
models slicing and dicing the data and
looking
at how our model performs in all these
uh
different subgroups are um directly
related to the quality of service of our
algorithms and models that we deploy in
the real world
so responsible ai should not be
considered as something that goes
against growth
but as an initiative that goes on in
parallel with initiatives for increasing
the quality
of our services increasing the coverage
of our services and also just you know
for
us in on the research side to be able to
better understand
what our models do and uh where we are
going as a fail
um it question
i'll i'll take the next question beta
thank you very much
and please have the questions coming we
are actively looking at the
q and a um live stream to see what
questions to take next
um and i see a question from lou um that
i would like to address next
lou is asking while many companies see
potential benefits of developing
responsible ai systems
there might be the responsible ai gap
between principles and tangible actions
due to the lack of knowledge of how to
cross the gap
how do you think academia and industry
can help reduce the gap
this is a great question lou and this is
something that we are
thinking about every day at microsoft
because this is a real problem
um one of the concerns here is that
this is a pretty new topic for everybody
in industrial
or an academia i think nobody was really
thinking a lot about
responsible ai five years ago and now
this is definitely a big
issue for a lot of us thinking about
these problems
so what this means is that we are not at
a very mature point in the understanding
of these problems or providing solutions
this is why as researchers we are
feeling very empowered at microsoft
because
the ideas we have that we are putting
into academic publications
can turn into products under a year this
you know analysis is just an example of
that but other tools like fair learn
and interpret ml are other examples of
research getting into practice really
quickly
so because of the very novel nature of
the problems and the solution space
academia and industry can work together
both in the understanding of these
problems and coming up with solutions
together
so so this is this is a space where
academia and industry can work a lot
together
i think um there is also an issue with
awareness and accountability
what i mean by that is there are other
problems we are just getting to know
right now
and academics revealing these problems
is definitely very useful
but accountability is another factor
we are dealing with some problems that
do not have easy solutions
and academics or industry research
partners revealing these problems and
presenting them in the public
also puts accountability for the
industry that is
developing these applications so i think
there are a lot of ways for academia and
industry to work together
and also i think it's the in some long
term it will be developing a responsible
ai standard for the whole industry to
follow
so that we can all be on the same page
about
responsible ai sabesa the next question
uh thanks aj um i'll respond to the most
recent question
here from amine they're asking could we
get any insight
on any production or usage of these
tools
and do you foresee any commercial use
for these types of tools
so i can share a few insights about how
these tools are are being used within
microsoft
there are a few things that we have
observed we have observed that different
teams can be at different levels of
maturity
so for example there are those that
have requests and asks for
other types of functionalities such as
for instance the feature extraction
um functionality that uh i share
the uh presentation this was uh
you know really a request that came um
internally from these teams
and uh there are other teams that are at
the level when
they need more help in learning on how
to adapt these tools in their everyday
cycle and uh we are trying you know to
support
both but uh it's something that one
needs to keep in mind when building this
tool
that you are going to be serving to
different types of um
customers and practitioners and we are
actually seeing this
also with um the open source offering of
the tools
in that also the external customers are
going to be at um
different levels and requests and um
this is something to keep in mind on the
commercial use we are thinking at the
moment of this as a
um you know as a platform to serve
developers and the commercial commercial
benefit will come
just from the fact that um with these
tools we are going to be able to build
better ai systems and models
and um we are going to have a better
coverage
just by uh being more rigorous in the
way how engineered this
um systems but of course uh you know
this uh these tools are part of an
ecosystem
like they don't live by themselves and
it is
uh we mentioned you know other tools
like fair learn there are
data exploration causal analysis and so
on
and as an ecosystem there is a lot of
value that they can provide to the
community
great what else do you have in mind aj
the next question
um i i will try to address actually two
of the questions that i see in the q a
because i think they are related
so first intro is asking could the
techniques you discuss provide an
understanding of data set drift or
concept rift
let model developers know when a trained
model has become become stale or
obsolete and needs to be trained on new
data
that's a very practical question and
kavya has an
um relevant question he's asking um
can this tool be used to understand how
backward compatibility and performance
differs from not for non-supervised
learning models so um both of these
questions are getting into use cases of
the error analysis and backward
compatibility tools
when the data set may not have labels or
error labels in them and the answer is
yes
we can actually use their analysis tool
to also understand how data is changing
in time
think about um instead of now using your
analysis
um with the error labels but but instead
the labels you want to
divide the data is whether this comes
from the original
training data or test data or the the
new data that is coming in
or you can divide the data into temporal
segments
and now use the same decision tree and
the matrix fields reviews to understand
how the all data and the new data
differs from each other
so now the label actually becomes the
time segment
of the where the data is coming in and
now you can use the tools
to find patterns that could separate how
the new data
is different from the old data and
through this you can actually have
interpretable patterns of data set drift
or concept drift so that's one use case
the current tooling can be used
and we are working on some new
visualization techniques that can make
it even more intuitive to understand
these kind of conceptual issues but even
the current tools
are applicable for those scenarios as
well
and coming back to caleo's question on
non-supervised learning models the same
thing actually applies here
for example let's say we are developing
different kind of
um models for example models that are
using different architectures
models that are that have different
complexity and we want to understand
how these different versions of the
models are different from each other
how are they making different decisions
so now
the label we can use in understanding
differences in error analysis could be
the cases where models agree with each
other and cases where models disagree
with each other
so then again we can learn now
different patterns of behavior that are
different between one model type and the
other model type
and this is also applicable to the venn
diagram that beta has shown for um
backward compatibility so now we can
actually look at
okay what are the cases that models are
working um
giving the same answer and what are the
cases that they are actually differing
so a lot of these visualization
techniques we have shown today
are not only about supervised learning
when there is a clear error label
with some creativity you can use them
for different
data drift or unsupervised learning
applications too
thank you aj um yeah so those are all
very interesting points um
sometimes we run into this sort of you
know findings and discoveries just by
visualizing the data better
uh on the backward compatibility example
that asia was giving
actually um i'm gonna share like a story
we were working on our kdd paper on
better understanding backward
compatibility and then we found out that
um by showing how backward compatible
points
are distributed in different classes or
different subgroups of the data
this could serve as as a good indicator
or as a diagnosis pointer
for understanding also where noise label
noise was
concentrated or feature noise so if
there was some
distributional shift happening in the
data that visualization could serve as
the first sort of like debugging point
that could take us back to the data for
us to better understand our noise or
other things that may have happened
um in the data set
um so i'll be taking another uh set of
questions this came up uh several times
either
on the questions on unsupervised models
or for example on other data types that
you might be working with
for example there was um a question from
arbor who was asking can i use this for
graph algorithms or are the tools
particular or specific to
a certain set of models um so the tools
are built to be
sort of a generic in the sense that they
take the model as a black box and as
long as you have a notion
of quality on the output of the model
then you should be able to to be using
the tools
however there are many you know other
opportunities um
out there to adapt these tools and build
more custom visualizations
or feature extractions that better
support uh
certain types of data we gave the
example on feature extraction for images
but there are other types of future
extraction that one can think about
you know graphs like or putting in there
the degree of the node or how connected
the component is
um or if you're working on language
using ideas from the um checklist
tool that uh marco in our group is
working on and
including them into error analysis so
there are a lot of opportunities
out there to make these tools you know
uh more
specific to the data type that you are
working on this is also one of the
reasons why we are making these tools
open source because we
acknowledge that um the community is
working
is um you know walking very fast towards
advancements
people use different models different
data types so if there is anything that
you would like
um you know to build for your own model
and data type
we're happy to take feedback and also uh
you know feel free to to send
issues on our github repositories or
other proposals or even contribute
yourself
thank you versa um i'll take the last
question if that's okay
and then unfortunately we are reaching
the end of our time today
um i've i've seen a few questions on the
q a um list that talks about
whether these tools are the you know
fundamental answer to the problems we
have in responsible ai
um whether um you know data
enhancement is the right approach or the
only approach when it comes to
addressing the blind spots we see in
ml models so i would like to
cover a few of these questions together
so first of
all data enhancement is only one of the
mitigation strategies that are
applicable when we see these kind of
reliability or bias problems in data
um other strategies could include
relating of different groups of data
in the training set so that we can
retrain the model and see if
models are getting better at paying
attention to a pardon
certain part of the data or um there are
techniques that could modify the
learning objective
of um of these models to actually have a
consideration in there to minimize the
difference in error rates between groups
and
the fair learn tool set has some
techniques already
built in in that in this so what we are
trying to do with the error analysis
and backward compatibility frameworks is
providing visibility
to model developers to be aware of where
errors are more concentrated and of
course then
they can take more informed decisions
about how to best
improve their models and data collection
is only one of these mitigation
techniques
and we want to actually we are currently
spending
our cycles on thinking about these
mitigations and hopefully you will see
mitigations being embedded into the area
analysis workflows
at the future releases but coming to the
question of
is our tools the fundamental answer
to the responsible ai challenge that
just we are seeing
definitely not this is why at the
beginning of
the webinar today i talked about
our responsible ar ai ecosystem
and here we are acknowledging that the
problems we are facing are not only
technology problems
but they are social technical problems
with components on culture
and organization um we need to actually
develop
a culture in ai development that is
aware of the impact that these
technologies are creating in the world
and give give comfort to t to teams
to work on these very challenging
problems that do not necessarily have
simple answers
at the same time thinking about why we
are what we are developing and why they
are
developing is a very fundamental
question
i've seen a question earlier that talks
about
using ai as a weapon this really gets to
the use cases
and the sensitive use reviews we are
doing in the company
again there is no technological tool
that will
really address the question of the
sensitive uses and the value judgments
humans are going to be bringing to the
table
so we have to complement the tools we
are developing
with the right culture organizational
structure
and human centered processes that can
really get teams to think about these
hard problems
so with that we are reaching the end of
our time today
i would visa and i would like to thank
you all for attending our webinar
um and this webinar will also be
available
on demand um for listening to it
afterwards
we appreciate your participation your
question and your interest in the
subject
and we would love to hear your feedback
if you get to use the tools and try them
on your data
please email us our emails
are available on the internet so we
would love to hear
your feedback about the tools and how it
has been useful for you or what other
functionalities you would like to see in
the future
if you're interested in learning more we
have listed some great resources in our
resource list there you can read about
some of the
academic papers that have been the
foundation for the work we presented
today
get links to the tools and also get
links to some of the blog posts we have
created that talks about
some of the work and the vision for
responsible ai
um i would like to wish you a great day
and
we hope to see you again at the future
webinar thank you very much
you